le musée départemental maurice denis
était de nouveau inauguré ce vendredi 17
septembre ancien hôpital royal situé à
saint germain en laye le bâtiment à près
de 300 ans d'existence
c'est un bâtiment ancien et les
bâtiments anciens s'entretiennent et le
musée départemental qui s'y est installé
en 1980 à 40 ans d'existence les travaux
de restauration débuté il y a trois ans
coût total des travaux 5 3 millions
d'euros on a mis en accessibilité le
site aussi bien en extérieur que à
l'intérieur pour faciliter
l'accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite et nous avons réfléchi les
salles d'exposition changer l'éclairage
et nous en avons profité aussi pour
réintroduire dans le parcours de visite
des éléments nouveaux quelques statues
des tablettes numériques
autre nouveauté l'exposition bonheur
rêver dédié à maurice denis elle
présente les oeuvres de l'artiste
peintre parmi elles f dans la forêt
c'est une évocation de de l'homme dans
la forêt de saint germain avant le péché
originel donc c'est à la fois c'est un
tableau de volupté avec un nu qui est
celui de sa seconde épouse et cette
question du corps de la volupté c'est
une chose qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans
l'exposition puisque c'est une
exposition sur l'intimité de maurice
denis donc on rentre vraiment dans sa
maison son épouse ses enfants sa famille
ses parents ses amis donc on rentre
vraiment dans sa vie
l'exposition permet d'inscrire le
peintre dans son territoire une centaine
de peintures de maurice denis sont
exposés